orchestre ont une telle aura celui qu'on
appelle l'eau angie présente un
programme consacré aux bandeaux naïveté
compositeur argentin astor piazzolla et
sera en concert entre autres ou prisma
elle en cour le 15 décembre pour nous en
parler voici daniel yvinec directeur
artistique de l'orchestré national de
jazz dans le kiosque
alors qu elle seule le jazz c'est une
institution qui existe depuis 26 ans qui
a une part qu de la particularité de
passer de main en main en fin de 2 des
mains d'un directeur musical à un autre
jusqu'à présent c'étaient des directeurs
musicaux qui jouaient leur musique pour
la plupart
ils sont arrivés qu'un hors caisse qui
étaient déjà constitués quand j'ai été
nommé en fait j'ai
décider enfin d'ailleurs même avant
puisque j'avais c'était présent dans mon
projet de monter un orchestre à partir
de rien avec des gens que je ne
connaissais pas et qui se connaissaient
pas non plus et je trouvais que c'était
une bonne opportunité justement d'aller
vers quelque chose d'un peu
inconfortable et pour eux pour le faire
grandir voilà donc j'ai auditionné des
musiciens pendant une période de trois
ou quatre mois j'en ai vu à 24,100
france j'ai recruté
dix musiciens
j'ai assemblé un orchestre un peu le
mutant avec des gens venus certains de
la musique électronique d'autres de la
pop de la musique contemporaine d'autres
du jazz on a une étiquette qui est leur
caisse national de jazz et à l'intérieur
de ça c'est un espace vraiment de
création libre ans
le dernier programme en date dont
l'album vient de sortir et qu'on
commence à jouer de plus en plus sur
scène là c'est un projet qui s'appelle
piazzolla avec un point d'exclamation
piazzolla c'est un compositeur qui
s'est frotté à plein de musiques
différentes pour moi c'est un peu un
graal de réussir un truc qui soit à la
fois très pointue et en même temps
destiné à tous
m
dans ce projet là j'ai fait appel à j'ai
travaillé avec un arrangement qui
s'appelle bingöl stein qui est qui et
new yorkais il a travel miles davis il a
travaillé avec guy les vans avec sting
avec paul simmons ça a donné une espèce
de sable mouvant comme ça pendant
quelques temps qui ont donné vraiment
une dynamique nouvelle à cet orchestre
il ya une dimension
qu'il faut souligner c'est que dans ce
programme j'ai pas cherché à faire
indice de tango déjà pour la simple
raison que on n'est pas des musiciens de
tango et que
dès 10h angot sur piazzolla ça a été
magnifiquement fait par lui-même donc
l'idée c'était d'avoir notre vision de
sa musique et se dire bon voilà
évidemment on va pas prendre de
bandonéon dans leur qu'istres d'une part
parce qu'il n'avait pas au départ et
aussi parce que chercher à jouer du
bandonéon comme piazzolla je pense que
il ya des gens qu'ils font et qui le
font très bien mais nous on n'était pas
du tout dans cette dans cette optique là
et l'idée c'était plutôt de recréer une
espèce de bandonéon un peu fantômes qui
apparaissaient et disparaissaient
étaient distribués un peu d'une manière
subliminale entre les mains de chacun
des membres de lorca
le disque on a enregistré
en cercle dans un studio sans casque
donc vraiment comme on faisait les 10
dans les années 50 enfin c'est un disque
on peut recréer facilement sur scène et
après sur scène pas forcément il ya une
dimension de liberté plus importante
parce qu'il ya une place plus grande
fête au soliste c'est une sorte de
voyage comme ça dans un monde
qui évoque les racines du tango carlos
gardel
le roberto di filippo qui est le un des
grands inspirateurs de 2k zola au
bandonéon dont les fantômes apparaissent
dans à la fois dans le disque et sur
scène
mais
il est temps de retrouver un nouveau
sujet de la rédaction présentée par lots
c'est à toi j'aurai la souris exactement
tonya kinzinger alias jessica dans la
série sous le soleil a rejoint la chaîne
nrj 12 pour présenter la nouvelle saison
de la star academy avec matthieu
delormeau ils présenteront chaque jeudi
en direct le prince où les élèves seront
jugés aux côtés de stars en france est
rare d'avoir un chanteur qui s'élançait
ou un acteur qui sait danser et chanter
aux états unis est déjà dans le culture
d'avoir cette polyvalence mais sa vie un
petit à petit en france j'ai juste suis
ravi ça permet aussi parfois de se
séparer ou verrez dans le plateau qu'on
sera pas forcément toujours sans menez
qui peut faire un lancement et pas
l'autre ça permet d'avoir effectivement
toutes les interviews américaine ce sera
avec des artistes internationaux ce sera
pour tenir la partie de plus de
française pour moi les élèves
intégreront la star academy pour la
neuvième saison de l'émission jeudi soir
les académiciens seront révélés au
public lors du premier prime et
découvriront alors le château de la
jeunesse situé à châteaufort bon il a
fait très froid un compte n'y était
là bas il en a fait des plateaux de la
semaine dernière là bas moi je la trouve
très belle elle est là elle est
entièrement refaite
très très moderne
tout dans un look musique jeunes un peu
tu n'es on va dire moi compris ce
château est donc tout n'est et non elle
est très très belle je pense qu'à
l'écran se racheter même si certains
couleur je n'aurais pas choisi
prochainement je les ai repéré les lieux
forcément je me suis bon à ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir aller courir dans wow quel
endroit s'il pleut parce qu'on a un abri
pour pouvoir travailler il ya des
couleurs vives c'est allé voir à
l'entrée dans très dur il ya une couleur
qui au réveil sept motifs tard ouais ça
motive ça motive ce que c'est une
couleur très
leur sang
après c'est la nature donc nous sommes
dehors donc c'est l'hiver meiway la
neige et où ça va coûter fois juste
couvrir c'est tout vous aurez sûrement
reconnu pascal l'ancien grand frère de
tf1 reconverti en coach sportif et
mental mais officiant toujours dans la
télé réalité
pas le but de ce qu'ils puissent tous
des pastous et tout parce qu'il ya aussi
des filles que tout le monde puisse
dépasser ses propres limites donc ça
c'est plus intéressant donc je vais
tester très rapidement les mythes de
chacun et puis le but c'est moi qui
puisse aller le plus loin possible aussi
bien dans le sport que dans la tête
parce que ça c'est important il faut
qu'ils avaient un mental très très fort
et pour que ce rendez vous le jeudi 6
décembre sur nrj 12 pour enfin découvrir
le nouvel intérieur du château de
lageneste à châteaufort
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
de mettre les boules dans le sapin les
frères ben haim exploseront les codes
des contes de fées avec leur spectacle
dansé l'ogresse des archives et son
chien le 14 décembre au prisme tandis
que cendrillon le mythique ballet de
maguy marin présenté par le ballet de
l'opéra de lyon soit au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 13 au 15
décembre juste avant where it like crohn
du cirque suédois circuit six records
qui sera présenté toujours au théâtre de
saint quentin du 18 au 23 décembre des
dates que vous pouvez retrouver sur
internet aux adresses qui s'affiché
cette semaine sur le
www.kia.ca qui point fr vous pouvez
gagner des places pour la petite
marchande d'allumettes de nicolas
liautard qui sera présenté à la ferme de
bel ébat alors bon spectacle à tous et à
bientôt